で あの次の最後のヤッタカーマ・ニパーティナンというところはね
まあ好きなところ 好きなところにべったり
何と言いますか 粘り  粘りつく
粘りつくんですね しがみつくんですね
だったら矛盾がないはずでしょうにね
好きなところに粘りついてしがみついているんだと
これが心のすごい複雑なところなんですよ
まあ本来は心は嫌なことをやりたくないんですよ
ある人を見たら なんて可愛い
美しいでしょうかと心がそうやって判断したら
ずっと考え方も思考も生き方も全部その人に合わせるんですよ
その人に気に入られるようにとかね
他はもうわからなくなっちゃうんです
それで幸せだ 幸せだとも言ったりするんです
心っていうのは好きな方向へ
好きなものにしがみついて粘りつくんです
まあありながら矛盾もあります
だって好きなものは自分のものにするためには並ならぬ演じる
演じを演出しないと だからその人に気に入ってくれるならば何でもやるぞと演じるんでしょ
だから両方いつでも両立する
だから苦しいんですよ
もし気に入ってる人でも現れたら
地獄のドア 門が開いたようなもんなんですよ
では 気に入ってる人は全然一人もいないんだったら天国ですかというと
それまた同じなんですね
また苦しいんです 誰か欲しい欲しいやと思っちゃうんです
まあ気に入ってる人がすぐ現れる人も現れない人もいますよ
これ何でしょうかね 結婚したいんですけど 60
歳になってもまだまだ見つかってない人もいるでしょ
でも18になる前にも結婚したいと父親と母親と喧嘩する女の子もいるでしょ
相手がいて もうあんたまだまだ年はないでしょと両親が怒るんですけど
構いませんと そんなことでと
なんででしょうかね あれは
そのうちいい人見つかるでしょうとかね
ずっと探してるんですけども
60にもなっていてっていう場合もあります
何だと思いますかね  理想が高い
じゃない もう単純ですよ
自分が何が好きかって
そのバカがわかってないんですよ
青犬が好きか黄色い犬好きか分かってないんですよ
青犬好きだと青犬の首輪あげればいいでしょ
それが世界は理想は高すぎじゃなくて
頭が悪すぎ 世間はそれは理想が高すぎやと一応言ってますが
もうどうせ世間の考え方だからね
事実はそうじゃなくて
頭が悪すぎ もうはっきりしないんですよ
だから小さい女の子たちだったら
いい この人は友達だからもう離しませんと
それで我々大人は言うんですよ
あんたまだ経験もないし
世の中もうちょっと自由にね
もういろいろ勉強して
いろいろものを見て もうちょっと大人しく大人になってから人を選んだ方がいいんではない？いいんですよ
それで はっきりしていますよ
好き嫌いは だからこの自分が何が好きか
何が嫌いかということは
ちょっとだけでも成立しちゃうと
もうすぐもうそこで淡々と
なんとか苦しめますけどね
もう淡々人生を任せると
どうせ苦しいだからね
で はっきりしていない人は
もう淡々じゃなくてごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃもうどうにもなくもう苦しむんですね
好き嫌いはっきりしている女の子は好きな人がいて
結婚して その人はろくに仕事をしないんだとか怒ったり苦しんだりはしていますけど
別にそういう形決まってる苦しみなんです
その場合はもうちょっと真面目に仕事をしてくれればね
子供に何とかもう服でも買ってあげるのにとかね
だからそういういろいろ
どっちにしても人生は苦しむことはもう避けられない
ぴったしついている現実
事実なんですね 人生といったって別に人生ではなくて心はなんですよ
人生はと言ったっていうのはね
心はということで 心が苦しむことにはもう決まっている
法則的に まあそういう法則にいろいろきめ細かく分析してあるのは仏教なんですよ
先生 躍起に 利他 他化利他ってなんですか？執着ということで言葉を聞いてもいいですか
だから何が好きか 何が嫌いか
はっきりしてるんだったら
もう心はすごい自動的に好きなところに行って
そちらにまっしぐらすぎて粘りすぎていて
そこで苦しみますけど
そこはもうある程度で
俗世間から見れば楽なんですけどね
でもこれは執着といえば明らかに執着のことで
でもその世界でまた演じなくちゃいけないんだからね
演じなくちゃいけない
大体好きなところに落ちたら
結構演じることには頑張るんですよ
演じる理由もそちらにあるんですよ
なんで我々は素直にならないで
人生そのものを一つの演出にしていて苦しんでいるのかというと
やっぱり好きなものあるんだからなんです
演出しないとそれにはたどり着かないんですよ
ですから 好きなものに粘りつくことと明らかな矛盾をするということは
そういうわけで もう共存しているんです
それが心ということなんです
そんなややこしいことは科学者は発見するはずもないんですよ
心理学も だから西洋心理学ではないんですね
心っていうことが 言ってはいますけど
意識やら無意識やら総合
何でしたっけ あの変な変な心理学を教えている人がね
役にも立たないカール・ユングさんのね
カール・ユングですね
ことをダラダラダラダラ言ってますけども
私はあんまり個人で好きじゃないんです
別にいろいろあちこち人々を言うことをね
東洋で言ってることとかね
ちょっとちょっとなめてもう入れているのは入れてますけどね
なんでその馬鹿の目から我々東洋文化をもうまた見なくちゃいけないんですかね
日本人がやればいいんで
私はやりません カール・ユングがそういうことをおっしゃってるんだから
東洋ではこういうこととかね
これはもうプライド持ってる人ないんです
だからあんまりどうったことないんですけど
それはシグムント・フロイトの分析はしっかりしていますけどね
きちんと イエスのはっきりしてね
そこは嫌がっちゃうみたいんですけどね
それより彼がね 心理学を発展させようと思ったんですが
でも無意識とかね 意識
総合無意識とかね ただ世の中の現象を何とかして説明しようとね
まあ頑張ってるだけのことで
理解してはないんです
だからこれはブッダにしかできることでもないし
人間に考えることもできないし
あまり心のこと考えるなとお釈迦様が言っています
それはもうわからないんだと
あんた方には マリア封鎖する
[背景音楽]